are you looking to do some hyper
parameter tuning on your machine
learning model
or perhaps you have other parameters
you'd like to be optimizing
your life then you've got to check out
ai platform optimizer
one of the newest products from the
google ai team
welcome to ai adventures where we
explore the arts science and tools of
machine learning
my name is yufeng guo and on this
episode we're going to dive into the
world of
optimization with ai platform optimizer
ai platform optimizer was built to
optimize hyper parameters of machine
learning models
so you can optimize things like learning
raid batch size and other typical
machine learning hyper parameters
this is the most common use case for
optimizer today but
wait there's more you can choose any
arbitrary values to tune
in fact it can optimize any evaluable
system for example you could use it to
determine the most effective combination
of
background color font size and link
color on a news website's subscription
button
this would take a b testing to a whole
new level or perhaps you need to find an
ideal buffer size and thread count to
minimize computing resources for a job
or maybe you need to optimize a cookie
recipe a bread recipe or
a brownie recipe to produce the most
delicious version
you can of course also optimize non-food
related things though i'm not sure why
you'd want to
anyhow let's talk about how to use ai
platform optimizer to optimize
your machine learning model or other
function there are three terms that we
need to understand
study configurations studies and
trials a study configuration is the
definition of the optimization
problem that you're trying to solve it
includes the result you would like to
optimize
as well as the parameters that affect
that result
those are basically the inputs that are
being optimized
a study is the implementation of
a study configuration a study uses its
configuration's goal
and input parameters to conduct
experiments
or trials so then a trial is just
a specific set of input values that
produce
some measured outcome ai platform
optimizer
only suggests input values for each
trial
but it doesn't run your trials for you
that
is your task and a study will continue
until it reaches a preset limit of
trials
or you end it so this means that as a
service
ai platform optimizer suggests trials
for you to run
records the outcomes of those trials and
then uses machine learning to suggest
future trials based on those outcomes
and you can continue this cycle for as
long as you please
now some of you may recall that ai
platform training
already has a built-in feature called
hypertune
which takes care of hyperparameter
tuning under the hood
hypertune uses the same technology as ai
platform optimizer
but whereas hypertune only works as part
of ai platform training
optimizer is a generic system that you
can use to optimize any system
any place this means that your model
could be training anywhere
your local machine a data center or on
another gcp service like compute engine
or kubernetes engine
anything that can make a rest api call
can use ai platform optimizer
and that flexibility is its true power
thanks for watching this episode of
cloud ai adventures
if you enjoyed it make sure to like the
video and subscribe to get all the
latest episodes
right when they come out i'm yufeng guo
on twitter at yufang g
and if you're looking for longer form
machine learning and cloud content
be sure to check out the adventures in
the cloud youtube channel which i've
linked below
in the description ready to give ai
platform optimizer a world
head on over to the documentation page
i've linked to in the description below
for all the details